>>> THE JANUARY 6 COMMITTEE WILL
HOLD WHAT COULD BE THE FINAL
PUBLIC HEARING THIS WEDNESDAY.
ONE RMER ADVISER TO THE
COMMTEE IS NOW RAISING NEW
QUESTIONS ABOUT WHAT WAS
HAPPENING INSIDE OF THE WHITE
HOUSE DURING THE JANUARY 6
INSURRECTION.
IN A NEW INTERVIEW, A FORMER
SENIOR TECHNICAL ADVISER DENVER
RIGGLEMAN SAID THAT A CAPITOL
RIOTER HAD A SHORT CALL WITH THE
WHITE HOUSE ON THE DAY OF THE
ATTACK.
>> WE GET A REAL AHA-MOMENT WHEN
YOU SEE THAT THE WHITE HOUSE
SWITCHBOARD HAD CONNECTED TO A
RIOTER'S PHONE WHILE IT WAS
HAPPENING.
>> SOMEONE IN THE WHITE HOUSE
WAS CALLING THE WHILE THE RIOT
WAS GOING ON.
>> SO A CALL FROM THE WHITE
HOUSE TO A RIOTER, RIGHT IN THE
MIDDLE OF THIS.
WHAT DO WE KNOW ABOUT THE CALL
AND HOW LONG IT WAS AND WHO
WITH-T WENT TO OR ANYTHING ELSE.
>> WE KNOW A FEW THINGS.
THIS IS THE ONLY KNOWN CALL FROM
A WHITE HOUSE TO THE RIOTER
WHILE THE RIOT WAS TAKING PLACE.
BUT THERE IS A FEW PLACES THINGS
ON HERE FROM JAMIE GANGEL AND
ELIZABETH STEWART.
THE PUBLICLY AVAILABLE NUMBER
FOR THE WHITE HOUSE, IT LASTS
FOR ONLY 9 SECONDS.
WHO PLACED THE CALL AND WHY
REMAINS A MYSTERY.
PHONE LOGS DON'T REVEAL ANY
EXTENSION OF THE LINE.
BUT WE HAVE LEARNED THAT THE
RIOTERS WHO RECEIVED THAT IS
NAMED ANTON LEWANIC FROM
BROOKLYN.
THEY WERE ONLY IN THE CAPITOL
FOR A FEW MINUTES AND HE'S SEEN
ON A CELL PHONE VIDEO LEAVING
THE CAPITOL BUILDING THROUGH A
WINDOW.
THAT CALL HAPPENED AFTER THEY
LEFT THE CAPITOL AND LEWANIC WAS
LIKELY ON HIS WAY BACK TO NEW
YORK, HIS HOME ALREADY.
ACCORDING TO ONE SOURCE THOUGH,
THE HOUSE COMMITTEE CONTINUES TO
INVESTIGATE THIS CALL BUT SO FAR
THEY'VE BEEN UNABLE TO DISCOVER
WHO PLACED IT OR WHY.
ZOE LOVE AGAIN DOWNPLAYED THE
COMMENTS YESTERDAY ON CNN.
HERE SHE IS ON THE COMMITTEE'S
WORK.
>> EVERYTHING THAT HE WAS ABLE
TO RELAY OR TO DISCERN PRIOR TO
HIS DEPARTURE HAS BEEN FOLLOWED
UP ON AND IN SOME CASES DIDN'T
REALLY PETER OUT OR THERE MIGHT
HAVE BEEN A DECISION, A
SUGGESTION THAT THERE WAS A
CONNECTION BETWEEN ONE NUMBER OR
ONE EMAIL AND A PERSON THAT
TURNED OUT NOT TO PAN OUT.
SO WE FOLLOW UP ON EVERYTHING.
>> SO EARLIER THIS YEAR, LEWANIC
AND HIS TWO FRIENDS PLEADED
GUILTY INTO FEDERAL COURT TO
DEMONSTRATED IN THE CAPITOL.
THEY WERE SENTENCED TO HOME
CONFINEMENT AND PROBATION.
ATTORNEYS FOR ALL THREE MEN
DECLINED TO COMMENT TO CNN AND
PROSECUTORS NEVER MENTIONED THIS
CALL DURING THE COURT
PROCEEDINGS.
BUT ACCORDING TO MULTIPLE
SOURCES FAMILIAR WITH THIS
INVESTIGATION, LEWANIC SAID HE
DOESN'T REMEMBER RECEIVING THE 9
SECOND CALL AND DOESN'T KNOW
ANYONE WHO WORKED IN THE TRUMP
WHITE HOUSE.
SO JIM, THERE IS STILL A LOT OF
MYSTERY HERE AND IT IS REALLY
HARD TO SAY AT THIS TIME HOW
SIGNIFICANT THIS DETAIL IS.
>> NO QUESTION.
OUTGOING CALL.
KAITLAN POLLANCE, THANK YOU VERY
MUCH.
LET'S GET INSIGHTS FROM MANU
RAJU.
SEUNG MIN KIM OF THE ASSOCIATED
PRESS AND FORMER FEDERAL
PROSECUTOR WU.
THAT'S THE FORMER CONGRESSMAN,
AN ADVISER TO THE COMMITTEE.
HE SAYS IT'S AN AH-HA MOMENT.
SEVERAL MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE
SAY MAYBE NOT.
>> I DON'T KNOW WHAT MR.
RIGGLEMAN IS DOING REALLY.
>> THAT'S ONE OF THOUSANDS OF
DETAILS THAT OBVIOUSLY THE
COMMITTEE IS AWARE OF.
>> WE HAVE BEEN VERY CAREFUL
ABOUT WHAT WE SAY, NOT TO OVER
STATE MATTERS, NOT TO UNDER
STATE MATTERS AND WITHOUT THE
ADVANTAGE OF THE ADDITIONAL
INFORMATION WE HAVE GATHERED
SINCE HE LEFT THE COMMITTEE, YOU
KNOW, I THINK IT POSES REAL RISK
TO BE SUGGESTING THINGS.
>> WHY ARE COMMITTEE MEMBERS SO
DOWN ON WHAT IT IS.
MAYBE THERE'S NOTHING THERE BUT
JUST THE IDEA THAT SOMEBODY FROM
THE WHITE HOUSE CALLED SOMEBODY
AT THE CAPITOL IN THE MIDDLE OF
THE RIOT, 17 MINUTES AFTER THE
PRESIDENT FINALLY SENT OUT THAT
MESSAGE GO HOME.
I WANT TO KNOW.
>> YEAH, THERE'S A COUPLE OF
REASONS, ONE OF WHICH IS WHAT
DENVER RIGGLEMAN IS SAYING IS
NOT SANCTIONED BY THE COMMITTEE.
THEY DID NOT WANT ANY STAFFERS
OR FORMER STAFFERS REVEALING
DETAILS BECAUSE OF THE CONCERNS
IT MAY SUGGEST SOMETHING THEY
SIMPLY DON'T KNOW THE ANSWER TO.
THEY HAVE A LOT OF QUESTIONS
THEY'RE TRYING TO SEARCH HERE
GOING FORWARD.
ALSO, THEY HAVE A MOUNTAIN OF
EVIDENCE AND A WHOLE HOST OF
OTHER ISSUES INVOLVING THE
PRESIDENT, INVOLVING HIS ALLIES,
INVOLVING THE EFFORTS TO
OVERTURN THE ELECTION.
INVOLVING WHAT HAPPENED ON THAT
DAY ON JANUARY 6th.
THEY WANT TO FOCUS ON THOSE
ISSUES, NOT CHASE THINGS THAT
MAY NOT AMOUNT TO MUCH, WHICH IS
WHY YOU'RE SEEING THIS PUSHBACK.
THE QUESTION WILL BE HOW MUCH IN
THIS HEARING THAT WILL COME UP
ON WEDNESDAY, HOW MUCH NEW
INFORMATION DO THEY PRESENT.
BECAUSE THEY PRESENTED A LOT SOR
SO
-- SO FAR.
THEY HAVE BEEN A LITTLE CAGEY.
>> BACK TO THAT IN ONE SECOND.
THIS IDEA, I GET WHY THE
COMMITTEE WANTS TO TELL THE
AMERICAN PEOPLE WHAT WE KNOW,
NOT WHAT WE THINK OR WHAT WE'RE
WORKING ON.
HOWEVER, THEY HAVE THE RECORDS
OF A CALL TO THE CELL PHONE FROM
456-4114, THE WHITE HOUSE
SWITCHBOARD, AS A PROSECUTOR,
CAN YOU FIND OUT, CAN YOU TRACE
BACK TO THE SYSTEM AND SAY WHERE
DID THIS COME FROM?
>> YOU CAN.
I THINK IN CASES LIKE THIS
INVOLVING WHITE HOUSE MEMBERS OF
CONGRESS, IF THIS WAS THE FBI OR
THE DOJ, THEY WOULD BE VERY
SENSE
SENSITIVE TO DRILLING DOWN TO
SEE WHOSE NUMBER IT WAS.
THE COMMITTEE MAYBE BE EQUALLY
AS SENSE TITIVE.
IT WOULD BE A VALUABLE ROAD MAP
TO HAVE.
THEIR CONCERN IS IF IT LEAKS OUT
PIECEMEAL, THE THERMAL DYNAMICS,
THE OBSERVATION AFFECTS THE
DATA.
IT CAN CAUSE PEOPLE TO TAILER
WHAT THEY'RE SAYING AND MESS UP
THE RESULTS THEY'RE GETTING FROM
THE INVESTIGATION.
>> SO THEY PREFER HE NOT TALK
ABOUT UNTIL THEY KNOW THE FULL
STORY, AND THEN WE HAVE THE BIG
HEARING, THE COMMITTEE TOOK THE
SUMMER OFF, COME BACK IN.
THIS COULD BE THE LAST
EVIDENTIARY HEARING LAYING OUT
THE INFORMATION.
ONE OF THE COMMITTEE MEMBERS
SAYS WE'RE LEARNING A LOT.
>> WE'RE GOING TO ON WEDNESDAY,
FILL IN THE DETAILS THAT HAVE
COME TO THE ATTENTION OF THE
COMMITTEE OVER THE LAST FIVE OR
SIX WEEKS.
IT MAY BE THE LAST INVESTIGATIVE
HEARING, WHERE WE'RE GOING TO
ROUND OUT THE NARRATIVE.
I'M HOPEFUL SPEAKING AS ONE
MEMBER WE WILL HAVE A HEARING
THAT LAYS OUT ALL OF OUR
LEGISLATIVE RECOMMENDATIONS.
>> EVERY PREVIOUS PEOPLE
HEARING, WE HAVE LEARNED A TON.
WE HAVE LEARNED A TON.
DO WE UNDERSTAND WHAT WE'RE
GOING TO GET ON WEDNESDAY?
>> IT'S NOT YET CLEAR.
OBVIOUSLY WE HAVE SEEN HOW
MEMBERS OF THE JANUARY 6th
COMMITTEE HAVEN'T YET
TELEGRAPHED WHAT WE'RE GOING TO
KNOW.
YOU'RE RIGHT.
WE HAVE LEARNED A LOT OF THINGS
FROM THE EIGHT OR SO PUBLIC
HEARINGS WE'VE HAD, AND A LOT OF
IT IS BECAUSE THEY HAVE BEEN SO,
YOU KNOW, SO RIGOROUS AND SO
DISCIPLINED WITH HOW LITTLE
INFORMATION THAT THEY WERE
KEEPING AMONGST THEMSELVES TO BE
ABLE TO PRESENT TO THE PUBLIC,
AND THEY HAVE DONE IT IN A
NUMBER OF WAYS.
THEY HAVE HIRED FORMER
TELEVISION PRODUCERS TO CREATE A
VERY COMPELLING NARRATIVE.
ZOE LOFGREN SAID THEY'RE GOING
TO DO IT IN DAYTIME THIS WEEK SO
FOX NEWS HAS A HIGHER CHANCE OF
AIRING THE HEARINGS TO REACH
CONSERVATIVE VIEWERS.
I THINK THAT'S WHY THE DENVER
RIGGLEMAN INTERVIEW WRANGLED THE
COMMITTEE MEMBERS.
IT WAS A VERY UNDISCIPLINED LEAK
FOR A COMMITTEE THAT HAS BEEN
VERY DISCIPLINED SO FAR.
>> IS THE GOAL IN TRYING TO
REACH MORE CONSERVATIVES BY
HAVING A INDDAYTIME HEARING IS
CHANGE THEIR MINDS.
OR IS IT TO INFLUENCE AN
ELECTION THAT WILL BE SIX WEEKS
FROM TOMORROW?
>> THAT COMMITTEE IS MOSTLY
DEMOCRATS.
YOU CAN'T TAKE THE POLITICAL
BACK DROP OUT OF THIS.
I ALSO THINK THERE HAVE BEEN
SUBSTA
SUBSTANTIATIVE DISCLOSURES IN
EVERY HEARING, AND THERE ARE
THINGS WE PROBABLY WON'T SEE
FLUSHED OUT IN THE HEARING THAT
ARE THE ONGOING WORK OF THE
COMMITTEE, WHETHER IT'S TALKING
WITH GINNI THOMAS, AND TRYING TO
UNDERSTAND ALL THAT COMES WITH
THAT, WIFE OF A SUPREME COURT
JUSTICE, WHETHER IT IS THE MIKE
PENCE ISSUE, WHICH CERTAINLY
SOUNDS LIKE THE COMMITTEE IS
THINKING ACTIVELY ABOUT WHETHER
TO TRY TO COMPEL MORE FROM THE
VICE PRESIDENT HIMSELF, NOT JUST
PEOPLE WHO SPEAK FOR HIM, AND
THEN THERE'S WHAT HAPPENS AFTER
THIS HEARING AND AFTER THE
ELECTION, WHICH IS WILL THERE BE
A REFERRAL, WHAT WILL THAT LOOK
LIKE.
LIZ CHENEY OFFERING CLUES OVER
THE WEEKEND SAYING SHE THINKS
ANYTHING THE COMMITTEE DECIDES
WILL BE UNANIMOUS.
READ WHAT YOU WANT TO.
WHAT I READ INTO, OR AT LEAST
WHAT I THINK I READ INTO IT,
THERE WAS A LOT TO COME BEYOND
THE HEARING.
AS JOURNALISTS WE WANT TO KNOW
EVERYTHING, INCLUDING WHAT
DENVER RIGGLEMAN KNOWS.
THE COMMITTEE KNOWS WHAT WE DO.
>> I TALKED TO JAMIE RASKIN
ABOUT THIS.
WILL THERE BE SIGNIFICANT NEW
INFORMATION REVEALED.
HE SAID IT'S IN THE EYE OF THE
BEHOLDER, WHICH IS DIFFERENT
THAN WHAT HE DID BEFORE.
MAJOR BOMB SHELLS IN PAST
HEARINGS.
I THINK WE'LL LEARN MORE ABOUT
THE SECRET SERVICE, AND HOW ALL
OF THOSE TEXT MESSAGES THAT WERE
DELETED ON JANUARY 6th IN THE
RUN UP TO JANUARY 6th, WITHIN
THE SECRET SERVICE.
WE COULD LEARN A LOT MORE ABOUT
EVERYTHING THAT WAS HAPPENING
AROUND DONALD TRUMP TO THE
RIGHT.
>> IF YOU THINK ABOUT THE
SEQUENCE OF HEARINGS AS A
PROSECUTION AND YOU WERE THE
PROSECUTOR, WHAT DO YOU WANT TO
DO AT THIS POINT, WHAT WOULD
YOUR GOAL BE, YOUR FINAL
EVIDENTIARY HEARING.
>> THAT'S THE DIFFERENCE BETWEEN
A CONGRESSIONAL HEARING AND A
TRIAL.
IF THERE WAS A TRIAL, YOU WANT
TO END UP WITH THE SUM UP AND
THE BOMB SHELL AND THE ASK TO
THE JURY.
I THINK HERE THEY HAVE HAD SO
MANY UNEXPECTED TANGENTS THEY
HAD TO GO DOWN AND RUN DOWN
SUBSTANTIVELY, THIS IS A NEW
AREA, THEY WANT TO PRESENT THE
FULL PICTURE.
I DON'T EXPECT IT TO LOOK LIKE A
SUMMATION IN A TRIAL.